Hello everybody! My name is Markiplier and welcome to Rain World.
Now Rain World is a game made by Adult Swim Games.
And if you know about Adult Swim and the games that they make,
the last game that I remember
was Rainbow Unicorn Attack.
But I know they've made a ton of other games since then,
and I'm willing to give this game the benefit of the doubt.
And not even that-
-oh hey
Oh that's so pretty!
Oh, this is so pretty,
A- And not that there's doubt to be given.
Because of course, they're gonna make fun games no matter what.
but this one, in particular, is very different
because it looks so pretty.
And the main character that you play as is one of these
Snake-like, rabbit, cat creatures that are just
Absolutely adorable.
and apparently this world-
-AWWW!
That's a baby!
Oh, that's a baby on your arm!
Oh, it's so cute!
It's a little family!
AWW! And the reason -uh-  like. Oh, they're hunting.
Oh, are those bats or moths? I can't tell.
Oh-ho! he's biting the head off of that one, oh my god!
Oh that's so- I guess they got to eat somehow.
But I want to play this one because it's so...
like artistically driven.
And in my mind, and this is because my own bi-
-OH, no.
This is because of my own bia-
-OH GOD,  NO-OH-OH!
NOO!
OH God! I was just watching!
I'm emotionally compromised already.
Oh, that poor wholesome family!
Oh, the wholesome meme that was that family!
Oh no. OH! That's who we play.
Oh, I thought that this was going to be like a tragic story
Of this family that loses every member of their family,
But maybe that's just because I've been playing too many dark games
and I just need to have a little bit more optimism about this.
But this game is supposedly,
very, very, challenging because, number 1,
Ohh...
OH Hi! I'm a snake cat!
Oh, I got a map.
I got a map!
Pick up, eat, throw, jump.
Not a lot to do here.
But this-this is supposedly very ch- OH look at my dinky dankey twinkle toes!
Oh God, I don't even walk on all fours.
Ohh I use it for...
whoa... what the hell...
Oh okay I'm very slanky.
Your'e hungry, find food.
IS BLUE FOOD???
CAN I EAT BLUE?????
God I don't know how to find food. Oh hello
Are you food?
Can I eat you? Eugh.... what are you?
OHH..Ok.
Ahh
I'm so slanky!
OHHH
What are you doing?
What are you doing?!
OHH.. You're giving me advice!
Well, I was going to try and eat you.
Oh ok, I can climb up the ropes and what not.
's very quiet...
(Turkey sounds)
Oh! Can I eat you?!
I remember my parents eatin' you!
(Markiplier noises)
(The unique sounds a Markiplier produces.)
Let me bite your head off here
I could have sworn this was-
This was the eat button... :c
Im pressin' the eat but.... did I eat it ?
I guess I ate it.
Ahhh you're trapped now! Got yah.
*cute noms*
Can I... can I.. nom you?
Im mashin' it.
OH I got to hold it down and then I... bite it to pieces...
Oh, that's incredibly morbid.
Well I'm going to do it anyway
Okay
*Marki-sound* hyergebershed
*angry nom* .,.
Mark so vicious :o
*Caution: Wild Markifart- may attack* o.0
God, I rip its wings off first!
Oh that's so horrifying!
Hey buddy!
Just one left... ok four is enough to hibernate with, apparently.
It's here? Wait they're here?!
I know they're here! I'm going to get you..(Mark noise)... got ya!
Too bad for you.
(great noises Mark) Okay.
Alright, additional food above four is kept
for later in my belly in the form of fat.
Alright, well thank you for all the
information, yellow, weird, fungal creature
that gives me advice and is also
computerized. Thank you for that!... oh
So supposedly, supposedly I say
supposedly guaranteed, there are a lot of
things that don't want me to live
In fact they may even want to eat me!
...Where you gone, hey! Hey come back here! Where're you
running off to! Hey I ate your whole
family! I lost my family therefore I have
no problem with that idea! I'm coming for you I got
you you're shouldn't have come up
here to my feeding grounds I guess I
could just catch it hold it I don't know
why I do that and let me go up here
first I know you got some advice for me
to do but I just want to... leap the gap?
I'll try.. what happened to my food did I
eat it already I can't even remember
apparently I did,how do I leap with the
gap? whoa get winded down... nope that's not
how you do it hey yeah thank you for
teaching me how to be me!!! ohhhh that's so cool!
I'm a slanky cat! oh my god! I'm.... ohhh what
is happening...
okay......
hello.....
why is it... like that
why is it like that..why is it like that.. why is it....
ok I don't know what's happening I don't
know what happening what the hell is
that! I don't know what that is do  I go down here?
okay what is this what's going on
okay! alright!  hoo boy! I don't know what's happening
hello this place is safe stay here to hibernate.
Oh God! But what about my family!
Oh... Ok.... yeah I feel real safe
Yeah I feel real safe with all the machinery is locked up beside me!
ok so the answer is
I'm in upside down two day, I'm gonna move on
to Japanese symbol that I don't
understand and then I need four food
every time I want to hibernate and then
it unlocks thankfully! thank you! good
thing all this machinery is here for me
so this speaks to another level in case
you guys like don't know like or maybe
I'm crazy but this speaks to another
level of what's going on here.
"There's food and shelter to be found, but beware of predators, go explore."
Thank You guardian! I guess I'm gonna just do my
thing, oh nice clue with light in the
background I like that
oh so pretty! Oh thats soo pretty!  but we're obviously in some
sort of post-apocalyptic world this is
the shell of a society that came before us.
Like that's super weird!
"Objects can be tossed" HUH! I tossed it real good.
Hhhg. Ok why do I toss it? Ah Food.
Come here food. Get you. Huh, yeah, see yeah you're gone.
Right. Nom nom. Nom. Nom nom nom. I saw you here .
There was another one there you go.
Oh. Oh, they burry under ground. Oh god.
Stop being a goof. Got you both. Nom nom nom. Nom.
It's a feast Hyha. Alright hmm so if I get down,
or if I jump up. Oh, hello where am I going?
where am I slanking off too? Hello.
Woh. I got a spear.
Nobody mess with me apparently I got a spear.
So what's lurking around in the darkness?
Hello? Hi? What are you try to tell me
here? Oh! There's some sort of generator
down there. Ah! But I'm not hundred percen-
Ooh... not hundred percent sure how to do that- OH!
Here we go. Where- Aah! I'm just in a hole in
the ground I'm just gonna stay here for
a while alrighty then (Random Mark Sound) all
right down no goddamn it come-on you
slanky cat stop being so- WHOA!!! What the
fuck is that?! Whoa boy! Well that's
terrifying where do they come from? Habooski! I
made it can I go up here I don't know
where this is gonna know that's not
gonna work fricka dig stop sliding off
everything got other things to worry
about apparently I'm gonna hold on to
this rock see I know what I gotta do I
know I'm a well aware of it blended nope
man let me really think about this but
nope let me throw this ah got you good
scared you didn't I yeah I could we're
not jumping know why am I not leaping?
leap elegantly leap like a gazelle leap
that- god damn it you lept then but not
close enough ya son of a badger come on
we gotta get over there got it leap nope
okay I gotta really wait. Leap!
deep bleep hot damn it LEAP fricking
LEAP goddamn it why the different done
is not doing it what I wantit to key okay
let's not be an idiot about this right
now do I need to get back to the shelter
but I just okay I'm gonna get back to
the shelter I suppose oh oh get down oh
boy okay all right then I'll get back to
the shelter Oh God okies I was following
me huh it's not the right way to go is
it I don't know you following me huh
alrighty then I think I'm okay maybe not
that I don't think it's still up there I
am pretty sure it is okay all right then
everything seems fine so I gotta leap
across the chasm again but hopefully not
into the maws of death that'd be nice ye
all right yes starting to get the hang
of this it is a bit it is a bit hard to
control sometimes like I'm not gonna
deny it is ooh I can pick up another
stickier and then not throw it that'd be
that'd be a good idea they're not throw
when I don't need to throw it ah a means
of escape oh yeah yeah yeah you don't
know I'm here do you God maybe he does
oh he's slankey to no no no no no no
no no no no okay or you don't know I'm
here I like that ah you don't even try
it oh god oh god oh god oh god oh god oh
god okay okay all right all right going
this way going this way they both went
that way which means it this way is
probably okay right that's how this
works oh please don't screw up my jumps
please don't screw up my jumps Oh on ye
okay where am I why is it all shaky are
the rains coming back here what's
happening not that one you douche ah
wait using where's it going Oh God okay
where did he go is he popping out
aaah I don't trust it hey is that the rains do I need
to get back don't know where I'm going
it's over it's the rains it's the rains
oh god I'm an idiot what have I done get
out of here get out get out get out I
don't know where these are taking each
that's not where I want to go I'll frick
a dick come on it's raining oh I guess
it's not hey I guess is everything okay
oh that's out now oh god damn oh god
ow what kind of heavy rain shit is that
fuck wow and just like that you're gone
jeezums was that my corpse okay where else
doing that over alright let's try to do
this a little less like a baby and let's
try to survive like an adult whatever
the hell species I am yeah alright so I
got to get food again cuz I died again
but at the same time now I know where to
go maybe and then I'll be able to do
what I gots to do OT all right there we
go got that point I got that barely by
the hair on my chinny chin chin you
sleep you better be asleep over there
huh with your twitchy head you doing
over there ah oh god oh god oh god I
didn't get in the hole ah ok come on I
guess uh why are you following me Rick a
dick ok I think we're fine they were
fine because if I can just I don't fall
like an idiot I should be ok uh that
doesn't look good oh well yeah yeah yeah
yeah you can't get me yeah here we go
perfect up right on the first try Oh
what an idiot you god damn it's god god
damn it god damn it god damn it don't
even try it don't even try it boy oh boy
oh this is a dead end isn't it ah ok all
right then let's try this what is that
dongen god there's so much food here but
I don't need you uh I'm I'm a nervous
wreck right now I mean number one I
don't have my family with me how did I
do that sweet backflip cuz that was
pretty awesome if I could remember how
to do that I might be able to capitalize
on it mmm barn key ok let's try this
again ye boi ski ok I don't know how you
got over the not that one god damn it
god get out no this doesn't look good
hey buddy how about you uh oh boy oh boy
oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy no no no no
oh no no oh god oh god ah hey iiiii oh
god oh god oh god oh god oh you're so
scary why are you so Carrie cheese on
what are you gonna do huh you gonna do
buddy you gonna do huh nothing you gotta
do nothing to me yeah that's right back
off back off I got a rock you want a
rock a rock in the face buddy oh you
want a rockin who you want a rug in the
face oh fuck fuck you up aah oh God all
right Danny let's let's uh let's let's
agree to disagree on that one because I
think I won that fight I'm pretty sure I
won that encounter yeah I don't think
anybody's gonna be mad at me for letting
him live and it's the moral choice I'm
stuck my head got caught up my own ass
are you doing in that corner over there
doesn't that doesn't look appropriate
ache the back take the back oh ok here
we go about a bigot decide wait so you
can just go up there wait so you can
just wait I tried to do that well I
tried to do that oh god oh god oh god
what I tried look I tried to do that it
didn't let me well is that about I tried
it you know where I am you do it oh boy
oh boy go go go frick I'm dead but I
tried to do that so I've been doing it
the hard way that no one's supposed to
go that way oh man it's just gonna show
him eating me oh it's just gonna show
I'm dragging my corpse error where 00
where are you taking me where's it
taking me I know I can restart at any
time I'm just like I just want to find
out where it's taking me you know in a
weird cosmic sense you know this isn't
any different than what i'm doing to
those bats there cuz I kill and eat
those bats so what does it really matter
well I like how this little yellow guy
is still following me around oh don't
fight over my corpse oh whoa what the
Frick was there oh ok they're just gonna
fight over me oh boy oh they're
literally fighting to the death over my
corpse oh what the hell okay I'm it's
good to know that I'm worth this even in
death ok so I'm going to take this very
intelligent path right here not that one
that would be that's not the intelligent
path ok and then well I don't know what
I found really cycle one outskirt I god
damnit freaky guy ok all right then oh
boy oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy back
flip back flip the fuck out of here
backflip into the next year oh fuck
wrong hole again goddammit I keep going
in the wrong goddamn hole
right but anyway I'm where I died to the
reins at least sweet backflips oh you
want some of this huh you want some of
this bro you want you want some of this
you can handle no no thats I got a rock
goddamn spear you want a piece on me
right yeah you can handle this you could
never handle this you don't even know
what handling this looks like so why
don't you just lay down let me be my
life okay anyway got you I don't even
know want you but okay I got you I guess
all right so where to go here I guess
the only way to go would be up whoa oh
so good such an acrobat I guess I'll you
I don't really want to be God not bad
why would you throw that not the bat all
right fine I gotta stick done Matt it's
all good down here maybe oh and then
maybe by climb out on this thing Oh ah
ok I got you okay I got it I don't
understand I don't understand but I I'm
gonna act like I understand and if I go
down this way sneaky vici like this and
then I go down this way I've made my way
farther I don't know father's good zoo
hey buddy hey buddy hey buddy hey buddy
hey buddy hey buddy holy whoa whoa whoa
whoa hey whoa whoa whoa whoa ah that's
equally as bad oh my god walk it's so
scary man all right I'm starting at the
hang of this game everyone ignore the
fact that I've band a bunch and let's
get to the heart of the matter which is
going wherever the hell I need to go I
just saw the green one Oh green ones to
you oh how can you do that to me how
could you do that to me go go go go go
go go Jesus go go um fucking go Hey Ya
Ya Ya Ya Ya Ya fucking go it's scary
this is scary I
scared okay all right then Danger Danger
Danger I know I know I know not that why
not pop brung fucking hole yeah goddamn
goober no don't do that no don't no
don't do that either do the opposite of
all those things okay doesn't know I'm
here okay all right you gonna move okay
no you didn't see any what are you doing
oh they're all coming after me okay all
right just got flip-flops my way through
here this tube is good you're not
supposed to be here alrighty then but do
you know I'm here I hope not how could
you how would you all right it's gonna
do some sweet backflips shred out to die
horribly no don't just jump okay yeah
yeah you thought you were gonna thought
you're gonna chase after be the answer
was you not and then you got screwed out
of a meal aren't you stupid feel hey
there's a lot of Pat's on that one I
said that's where they hide oh why did
you do backflips off of that what did
you suddenly backflip what did you do 10
million backwards why would you do that
now he's just gonna stand there ah so
mad how Danny he's in the one place I
need to pray okay were you I god damn it
I don't know what's happening he's got
me okay well walk why would he back flap
wedge gonna nanana nanana slinky Dan
nnnnnn Annette vegan then nnnn Anna
don't eat me oh fuck dude it's you I
like green skin it's really cool now
don't eat me look at me balancing like
bad aster dared enter dude do don't me
you son of a bitch ass earth to turn to
dirt dirt dirt dirt or 32 oh god oh god
oh god miss me miss me a big fat douche
mid to do booboo milk and a crime this
goddamn poll now 50 big o fuck me yeah
oh god oh god oh god yeah you missed me
you stupid bitch I got nothing against
you please don't kill me I don't want to
die oh god please don't kill me oh fuck
all right haha hi you dummy hi you
Donnie ok let me know it's just not
backflip not that clip would be good do
oh my god you almost did it ok so for
some reason when you like land on the
ground sometimes you do a sweet flip and
that fuck i wanted that damn it i don't
want rocks i wanted to throw the rock so
i could have this stick but you know
what sometimes you just don't get sick
you just don't get sick like that's
that's life that's all they're fighting
are you fighting over something or are
you just fighting in general I'm gonna
sneak gone by you now they'd better do
booboo fail hey look at me I'm dancing
on a pole now passed after Oh pal but
not like that it's kind of cool I guess
what video ok miss me fuck you fuck you
buddy I'm going up here now boo doo de
doo pitcher Tudor look at all these
fucking poles babe Stern electors dr.
Acrobat is my profession doo doo boo boo
boo not this whole you stupid bitch all
right here we go boink boink yeah to the
bank oh that is it okay I don't know
where we're going but we're making a lot
of profit I made it to another son no oh
god oh god oh god get up there uh oh
yeah okay maybe it was all a lie what
the Frick is that what was he saying
about this area but there was another
safe house over there who stick I like a
stick or a really well one of those guys
with this stick here okay I don't know
what those sounds are that I'm hearing
but I see you well I'm not going in
there when you're in there oh you think
I'm a dumb dumb and I'm just gonna waltz
into your mouth oh not today
not d not today baby not today oh boy
he's coming after me how about a big ol
stick to the face oh god he liked it he
liked it he liked it I didn't know he'd
like it I was under the impression that
he would not love god did I just robbed
or knocked myself Oh goddamn it you're
fucking wall jump I was never good at
this good okay alright so we're in a
conundrum right now little boy don't
know how to get away from it ooh boy oh
boy all right you wanna you want to go
with me you bastard i'm going to go no
no no no no okay so we got a bit of an
issue here seem to be a little off haha
he did not know too stupid I see ah you
went the wrong way I have the high
ground you can't possibly win okay okay
we got to get up there because
apparently the guy is telling us that
something's up there and and you know i
do i always do what I'm told so here we
go slank in our way Oh does that mean
halfway done we got to get back soon I
got time AWS i'm on my way to us i'm
following the yellow brick road oh hello
I hope I'm going the right way how am I
uh I will be able to get up here ok this
was a long convoluted path to get up
here ah alright go and go and go and go
and go and go and I feel like I've made
a lot of stress right now I don't like
it too much but here we go boink what's
up here whoa what's up there what is
that what's this hologram well just show
it to me I don't know what that means
but I'm gonna go for it I trusted you
thus far from where am I OOP do climbing
up ol do-do-do-do-do-do-do the Frick is
all this
it's not comforting that there's just an
alarm going off the flawed as bad what
is that Oh God oh that's what the alarm
was oh I think those are the day symbols
so I can't come back here until those
days which is just about to happen now
oh but I'm far away oh god it really
screwed me over on this one I've got it
how do I get up there oh I can't get up
there again ha-ah no I can't I can't do
it I got to go this way oh man but am I
safe from the reins in here no probably
not where am I I don't know where I am
not that one maybe it was that one it
was that one God god damn it I'm sorry
I'm such a panic right now I got to get
back because otherwise all this progress
is gonna mean nothing I'm gonna die
where am I now gee what is G mean I
don't know what genes you come away from
all the Predators Jesus okay I'll go up
here I guess I don't know where am I now
oh you wanna you wanna you want to
freaking stick to the face I will stick
you so good hmm you ain't gonna know
what don't stick you yeah that's right
you better run alright so if I get up
here and then freakin yeah no that
didn't work oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy
oh boy you want to get sick probably dad
get up off rock this is hard it's like
really really really hard he's taking me
to his g cave goddamn it not the g-spot
fuck alright so this is really hard
there's like ridiculously hard
because one I don't know the levels and
I don't know the lamp but it's so it's
so intriguing like it's just really
intriguing what and what is wrong with
you purple freaks what is wrong with you
what do you twitch what he whose
radiation and what are the symbols mean
I'm just a weird slinky cat I'm a snake
bunny been anyway that's all the time I
got for this episode but this is really
really interesting I want to play more
this I want to play so much more this is
so cool I don't even know what it is
about it because I don't know the
universe but that's what makes it cool
why am I here where did all this
machinery come from one of those
creatures where's my family would my dad
be able to kick their ass my bet is yes
huh what is cool want to play more so
I'm going to play more so thank you
everybody so much for watching let me
know what you think down the comments
below and as always that will see you in
the next video
BUH BYE :D
Have a nice day everyone!